why is it important for you of all the
events you go to day in day out here in
Hollywood this one is very important why
was it important for you to be here so
I love giving money away I love the idea
that we make money as an industry but I
love to go to an event where it's
focused not about us not about like our
work it's about the work of young people
coming up and I I love the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association who do the
Golden Globes because they do a granting
dinner every year where they give away
millions and millions of dollars to film
preservation Etc similarly here I like
that a group of women all
active creative artists are coming
together to help young women who are
rising up and need that lovely support
it's inspiring and I saw you posing with
your sweet friend Jennifer Gray are you
two having a little breakfast date this
morning you know what Jennifer and I
love each other and there she is and um
she's been working and I've been working
and we haven't seen each other so to me
be able to no and I just gave Heidi
Shafer a copy I just think about it so I
literally just brought Heidi Shafer a
copy of Jennifer's book in her holiday
bag literally there's a whole bag right
here from my company my hand in yours
and I happened to give Heidi a copy of
Jennifer's Jennifer are you loving this
moment right now
listen get you a friend who brings your
book to the red carpet she didn't know I
was coming I didn't know it no no we
didn't know it no we talked
but we didn't connect Hollywood right
why do you have my book here are you
reading it like during the session I
gave it to Heidi as a holiday gift
foreign
I'm hoping you can share some uh some
holiday news for us any updates with a
Freaky Friday reboot I love that little
laugh but I think you better call uh Mr
Iger and uh ask him but we're talking
about it for sure right you said that
you've been talking to the right people
no we're we're talking about it for sure
have you seen Lindsay's new Christmas
movie no no I've been working but yes
I'm going to I've told her she is
the best we gotta get you two back
together we will
we will see we will
[Music]